two weeks after the news of his
intention to resign emerged and amid a
deadlock between sudan's political
parties prime minister abdullah
announced he was stepping down from his
position
despite my efforts to achieve the
necessary consensus to be able to
deliver to our people the promise of
peace justice and no bloodshed that did
not happen during the past few days i
met with all the civilian and military
officials of the transitional council to
explain and put the patriotic and
historic responsibility in front of them
following what i stated i have decided
to return to you what you entrusted me
with and i announced my resignation from
the post of prime minister
abdullah emerged as leader in 2019 after
the overthrow of sudan's authoritarian
president ahmad bashir the country's
main civilian coalition the forces of
freedom and change saw hamdug as the man
to help sudan transition from
dictatorship to democracy
he had previously worked in the ministry
of finance before taking up top jobs in
the african development fund and serving
as the deputy commissioner of the u.n
economic commission for africa
as prime minister hamduk oversaw a
severe financial crisis during which
inflation started beyond 400 percent
but he still managed to end the civil
conflict in various parts of the country
with the juba peace agreement of october
2020
he also successfully lobbied the u.s and
the world bank to remove sudan from the
list of sponsors of terrorism and
convince global financial institutions
to provide debt relief and economic aid
but in october this year the military
led by abdel fattah al-burhan staged a
takeover placing prime minister hamduk
under house arrest and putting members
of his cabinet in prison
a month later hamduk was released and
reinstated after international
condemnation of the coup he then signed
a deal to form a government of
technocrats sidelining political groups
but many sudanese felt he had betrayed
the revolution his removal as far as
they're concerned removes the last fig
leaf that was covering this regime and
what remains is a full-fledged military
military dictatorship so i think the
international community will now uh will
likely increase its pressure on the
military regime uh with the uh hope of
uh heeding the demands of the sudanese
street and and
installing a full civilian rule
demonstrations against the military and
the deal hamdock signed with them have
led to the killings of dozens of
protesters by police and security forces
hamduck has been unable to stop the
violence or install a government that
would remove military interference
and now it seems he is left with no
choice but to concede defeat and resign
hiba morgan al jazeera horton